6 43 it is Monday morning using your
story to inspire others and what a story
joined by Bruce Wayne Brackett also
known as
bwb.positivity on Instagram and Tick
Tock you're what what the kids say a
viral a viral sensation but your story
is incredible from um being you're
really an advocate on recovery and
addiction and spreading positivity a
former Las Vegas now in New York so you
came back because you received an award
with the cheer Choice Awards last night
yes yes talk about that because that is
that's all about spreading positivity
and engaging especially young followers
yes absolutely and it was such an
incredible honor to be a part of I was
nominated for motivational
speaking and inspiration and although I
did not win just by being nominated
amongst thousands of people was truly
just the honor and being able to see
what it is that other creators are doing
and spreading Joy love and positivity
was really rewarding and just to meet
them in person was incredible so let's
talk about your social media a little
bit and how you use that to not only
share well to certainly share your story
but to share moving forward your story
of the struggles with addiction and the
challenges you faced through your life
leading up to now how does social media
help and what do you try and tell people
I have a formula of three one do I want
to see this in the world two do I think
that this will provide any good to the
world and three do I need to hear this
if I need to hear it chances are there
are so many others that need to hear it
too I was in a spot not too long ago and
I'm sure in my future as well where I'm
gonna hit that road of that that mental
block of feeling that I'm alone I'm not
going to be over uh be able to overcome
this and it's just not true when we're
able to show up with in our authentic
way and we ask for help we put ourselves
out there it's amazing the response that
can come from that so you are not alone
asking for help is so difficult like you
were a youth here struggling in Las
Vegas and and surely there's people out
there in that same situation what advice
do you have for them or maybe for the
family members who are seeing a young
adult going through something that they
don't understand but they know they need
some assistance absolutely that's a
wonderful question
um and I believe that
for
I believe it takes a pause I believe it
it takes because we want to help so much
and sometimes by overhelping we're
actually pushing them away from the help
that it is that they're really needing
so to be able to stop and listen
and truly just listen to what it is just
to realize yes I understand that you
were going through something and I'm
here when you are ready to receive the
help or to ask for help so we can push
but we really can't make anything happen
until that that person is ready so just
sit back with love be patient and
pray it's the right things will come
it's an important story certainly it's
an important uh goal of positivity and
certainly ask the question and and reach
out and follow Bruce's Journey online as
well you're on social media of course
that's how you're here uh we appreciate
the time thank you very much thank you
for having me thank you I love that
congratulations on on your journey and
and where you've been thank you same to
you